Carly we often hear that screenwriters
shouldn't always write their personal
story because they're so close to it
yeah do you feel that's a myth I think
you can perfectly do it it doesn't you
have to know that it has good things and
bad things you know so in my case I
think it's very interesting when you
like I need to have some kind of
connection to be able to talk about
something you know but when you talk
about something that you know so well
because it's your own life you have this
access to the material and you can it's
like you can ask answer any question
about these characters any what would
happen in about why it happened or why
they feel like that you know so you can
answer any question to your actors and
also to your crew and for me that's very
interesting you know like you have where
you can portray the world in a very
complex way you know because you know a
lot about what they are talking about
but obviously then you have to find the
right distance you know and to be able
to talk about that and that's difficult
as a screenwriter and also a Thai actor
when you are in the shooting you know so
that's the the difficult part so that's
what you mean by maybe the bad things is
is finding that just yes yes exactly so
I think that the the difficult part is
to just not fall into some kind like to
be able to be kind of objective you know
and and objective you say yeah yeah so
so yeah to kind of portray the the good
part person the bad parts of the
characters you know and and just not so
you like for me I felt this sense of
responsibility to be fair to the
characters because they exist but at the
same time I discovered that they
probably made some mistakes on their way
as well you know so I had to also
explain that you know but it's by the a
I think it makes it more interesting you
know absolutely I think you had a
teacher when you attended a London Film
School yes and
that professor or teacher encouraged you
for your first feature to write about
what you know yes and you took it
literally yes you can you talk about was
it like an aha moment where you're
sitting in class or where you said I'm
going to do this hmm well it's like like
the philosophy a bit of the London Film
School it's a lot about because it's so
international so you have people from
everywhere so you they kind of encourage
you to to see what defines you you know
in any way and see where you come from
and kind of talk about what you know so
for me it was a mix between what this
teacher told me and also about being far
from my home you know so suddenly you
miss your family in your place you give
more value to it and you realize that
that this is what makes you different to
all these people that come from all over
the world you know so um so it was a mix
between that and the fact that I made a
short film about two siblings that found
their grandmother so when I finished
that short I realized that that
basically a children facing that was
something that there that was very
interesting for me and and the day that
I really wanted to to kind of talk about
that and keep exploring this game and
and kind of give my point of view about
it I was looking at some of the trailers
for your work and you had one and
forgive me for my my Spanish here but
the spookiness Casas yes those little
things yes and it looked fascinating I
haven't seen the full film but when
you're coming up with questions for your
film or when you're about to make one
whether it's a short or featured what
are some of the questions that you're
asking yourself when I start writing you
mean oh yeah for a story idea mm-hmm
usually it's about so I try to think a
lot about whose story it is and I'm fine
if it's not just one person's story you
know like I think I try to think about
the point of view and because these
leads me to think about the emotions you
know so I I quit
to myself a lot how they feel you know
and then I usually try to find like a
time frame that's something very
important they can just beginners course
it was three days in now they like with
they were film it was three months
summer you know so for me it's important
to kind of find yeah it's a this
timeframe you know and then I think a
lot of adults about the backstory of the
characters because there is something
that I I love to portray a specific
moment of the lives of these characters
I like when you feel that they have a
lot of things that happen between them
before you know so so it's like
basically we as a human beings are who
we are because of all of our backstory
you know so I love observing people like
in real life and see how their
relationships work you know and and I
always wonder why you know so I try to
kind of imagine their backstory so
that's that's like my little game with
the people I mean even also so that's
something that I really like to do as
well when I start writing and saying
okay so the audience are just gonna see
this moment by what's behind that like
what's before all that you know hmm
right you just such an excellent job in
summer of 93 with just the looks that
these characters would have and that
there was this tension and you didn't
know at first what it was but there was
this hushed tones or and you would see
the looks on freitas face of concern and
and I love that because I went in cold
not knowing what the movie was about and
it built up to that but I think you said
that you believe that the audience is
intelligent enough to understand complex
emotions without showing or scuse me
without saying a lot you talk about that
yes it does that for me it's a
interesting so basically when you
in real life you know like you don't
always have someone telling everything
that's happening or people telling
exactly how they feel you know so real
life is not sometimes it is but
sometimes it's not so explicit you know
so and I like when it's like that
because so I like to show this in the
film you know like somehow to establish
this game with the audience way you just
put them into a situation and they you
give them some information here and
there and then they have to kind of lean
this and understand the relationships
between the characters and understand
what just happened and all that you know
so for me it's the game with the
audience that obviously they they have
to think a bit you know and I but for me
I feel this is more interesting you know
so and it's a way to so I like saternus
somehow you know on the way of
explaining things and also because
there's something I always think there
is something that it's very revealing to
me that when I write something and I
think okay do I want to shoot this that
it's is it
do I have a visa to shoot this scene and
usually when they have a lot of dialogue
and a lot of talking and explaining
things I am like it's boring you know I
don't really feel like I want to shoot
this you know so this is kind of like a
good thing for me to know and and then I
end up like taking out all the dialogue
and just explaining things with little
gestures you know and because I really
feel like shooting this more than just
that you know you know hmm
so let's talk about the day you actually
sat down to write it or maybe you
actually already wrote this years ahead
and you finally I'm not sure but no not
really it was actually um so after
making this short I decided I wanted to
start making like I wanted to make this
as a first film and and I was about to
make my dad film for the further London
Film School so I tried to write a short
about that and I realized that it was
too short and I needed more time to
explain the story so that's why I went
to to do let's begin disclosures so the
idea was there and and I showed my great
film in my village so it was very
inspiring to be
can and to start thinking about this
story and I actually started writing
when I finished the school and that was
June 2014 more or less and we should do
we should summer 2016 so it was about
two years but the first step to write
the discrete it was to go to my parents
place when I say my parents I mean my
adoptive parents and and I spent some
days there and I tried I talked a lot to
them and I kind of asked them a lot of
questions and try to make them remember
some situations that we lived when I
arrived there and I also scan all the
pictures of my childhood and because
they were being spying you know the
thing is that my memory was very
abstract you know like I could I could
remember some emotions but I didn't
remember like lots of specific things
you know so if the photos were very
useful because the take they are a way
to keep the memories you know and there
is a story behind each foot so it was
rained
they were very inspiring so between what
I could remember and my my family
stories and also these photos I wrote
like a first draft of the script and
that was it was actually very fast I
don't think I will ever write something
that fast because it was like in a week
I wrote this first draft but then
obviously it didn't have much sense you
know it was just these moments together
it would have been a non-narrative film
somehow you know so then I it was when I
started to read a lot about children's
psychology and how what what the kid can
understand when they are six years old
about death you know and the adoption
processes and all that so so it was a
way for me to understand the journey of
Frida when the same why I acted as I
acted as a child you know
so it was very interesting to kind of do
this research and this helped me a lot
to kind of organize the script and
working with the emotional are you say
that of the character and in actually I
made them so there's a lot of things
that I invented like in the film
actually they're like three or four
scenes that are real in the rest is
fiction but they it all in the starting
point of everything is like emotions or
some things that that really happened
you know at what point did you have as
Valentina V so she came in and and did
she look at it after you had several
incarnations of the script valentina a
so we met in a in a workshop in the lab
and and I really like her work and the
director she work with and basically so
I wrote the script myself but I at some
point in their to finish the sketch you
know so and this is something that it's
very hard to say okay I finished very
you know so I call Valentina and I said
I need you to help me to finish the
script and say okay it's done I can just
go and shoot it you know so we sat down
sometimes and and she was very useful to
kind of say okay that's good like to
give me this confidence you know and
sometimes some ideas to kind of fix that
let the little problems that that I
still had with the script so she came at
the very last part of the script and for
me it was very interesting to work with
her and to kind of like just feel that
it was done you know but there were a
lot of people actually um so I did a lot
of screenwriting workshops and I had a
lot of feedback constantly from
different people and at some point I
also work with the script editor that we
were together for a week to kind of also
keep rewriting and Valentina came at the
at the bay and to kind of finish it so
it's like I wrote in myself but it it's
for me it's very important to constantly
have this feedback also because it was
this personal material you know so
suddenly it's like there are some things
that you feel they are so important
and and you have you need to have
someone from outside telling you maybe
this is just because you like that or
that's very emotional for you but it's
not so important for the story you know
so um so all this feedback was actually
very very useful doing the whole process
you know at any point did you think well
maybe I'll just sell the screenplay and
have someone else make it or did you
know that I want to write this and I
want to shoot it as well yeah I never
thought of leaving someone there egg
because I love their I think you know
and I love working with kids and and and
I love writing but it just for me it
goes together like I don't I don't see
how you could separate that like I I
could see myself directing someone else
work but I I like I don't see myself
just writing for someone maybe like at
some point but but for me it is like
when I write I I think about how I want
to shoot it you know so it's very much
related and yes so it and it also was my
story so it's that's why also it's it
was important for me to today active do
you feel like you were ready to tell
this years ago or whether there points
where maybe you I don't know lady embed
it and I thinking I don't know if I can
share this because it is so personal you
know it's a lot to put your own story
whatever it is out there because maybe
people like it maybe they'll be critical
maybe they'll feel something but it's a
risk um yeah the thing is um it's like
I'm 30 now and this happened when I was
six and I was lucky to to grow into a
family where we always share this like
in an open way and we always talk about
it and so it's like I've been explaining
my story all my life you know so it kind
of became a story in that or a tale you
know so for me I could really see it as
a story because I that's how like I knew
how people reacted when I was explaining
them what I had lived you know so and I
thought that there was something
interesting there
and and yeah I didn't like I don't I
didn't make the film because I needed to
make a catharsis or kind of like like
heal something because I feel that I I
really had the adjusted this story a
long time ago you know and I I don't
think you can make a film if you are not
in that position you know because then
you can get the right distance it's just
very difficult you know so for me it was
a it was just a way of reconnecting
reconnect with my with my past and just
think about how the the people that
surround me felt and why I acted as I
acted so it's like I learned a lot about
my family but but I didn't need to hear
something somehow you know right what's
your advice for other aspiring writer
directors on wanting to tell their own
story and having that distance and I
think as you said previously analyzing
yourself you think that that's good hmm
I would say that they pick some people
that they trust a lot like creatively
wise and I listen to them you know like
like for me it's important to let's let
those people read the script and listen
to the comments you know you may take it
or not but it's good to have this
feedback from time to time when you're
working with something very personal
because um it's easier to get lost or to
just feel that something it's very
important it maybe it's not as important
for the for the story so for me the
whole writing in the whole writing
process the feedback was something that
that that it was so important and I'll
see if you have a producer already
attached this this producer is also a
person that can can give you this kind
of advice as well you know are you
surprised at how I've taken people are
with the film like I mean we're sitting
here the Academy Awards are coming up in
just a few months yes totally that for
me it's just I just wanted to tell my
story because I thought that I had the
point of view on how a child faces the
bay
you know and my producer always said but
I think that I can be a story that can
touch touch many people you know and I
wasn't sure I was like okay if you say
so you know but I couldn't imagine so
the first time that we we screen the
filming in Berlin and and the project a
big screening room and there were a lot
of people and then the lights went on
and there were a lot of people crying
and I just I was in shock I couldn't
understand why and then after that like
talking to people you realize that there
it is a universal story as a topic as me
in myself you know it's just that he
talked about childhood and family and
death so somehow people feel related to
that but I was not expecting are you ok
talking about how you finance the movie
yeah yeah sure so basically it's a it's
mainly the Spanish money we had a found
from media from that it's a it's from
Europe for development so this was great
but it's not much money but it's very
good to start the funding process
because it's a sign of quality somehow
you know so then we went to the Spanish
government and we ask for funds there we
got it and we also good Catalan
government funds and and after that we
got the Spanish public TV getting the
film so they put quite a lot of money as
well and we went shooting with that mmm
and I was eight hundred fifty thousand
euros so I actually wanted I needed to
shoot more wigs but we could only shoot
six weeks because the kids can only
shoot air from six to eight hours per
day so it was really really fast shoot
but we didn't have more money to shoot
more more time so it was okay at the end
but it was just kind of we suffer quite
a lot during the shooting because of the
time but then after that we also had the
Catalan public TV and movie star plus
which is like the canal closing in
France and this was very useful because
it was like we could finish the film
properly you know so there's little
budget is about a million more or less
this is more fear and to get the the
process going you had to show them the
completed script or did you just have an
outline in the beginning sort so for
media because it's development you just
have a treatment but for the rest yes
you have to have a great it may not be
the last draft but it's important for
them to to see if there is a story there
you know so and it don't seem very
important like the
the directors a statement you know and
for them to see how you want to shoot
the film and how you want to work with
actors and all that you know so we had a
very kind of like so sheer telling how
how I wanted to shoot the film and also
how the producers wanted to produce it
and all that so um and with some
references so it was this this document
in the script and then they they have a
reading committee and in this committee
gives your mark and then they just give
money to the higher marks and it's it's
quite competitive it's very it's very
difficult
but yeah so it's it if they liked the
project and this we were very lucky
because it would happen so so then you
are fine getting this public money but
it's not easy and the location that you
shot it out was of course where you
spent time with your new family but
you'd been back since you were a child
obviously using that location okay I
mean I grew up there auntie and then I
left when I was seventeen to put to stay
to university but my parents are still
live there
so I go to visit them very often and my
siblings now they live in Barcelona as
well so we are like my because after
summer 1993 we had a brother so we only
live in Barcelona now that we my parents
are still there and actually my siblings
my sister so Ana in the film she became
an actress and she's in the film and my
brother is a musician and he made the
music of the film so it was very nice to
do work with them on yes the dynamics
between Frida and Ana those were the
real the real sort of interactions I
know you said some of the parts were
real and some were maybe more
embellished or they were changed but the
looks that they were priceless I mean I
know you said you didn't really give the
script to the the child actors but the
looks of the seemed it's as if Ana was
in awe of Frida and also maybe jealous
at times but there was an awe you could
see on her face yes the thing is that we
we pick against who where we'd like
characters I had written and it was also
a important the combination between them
so we try different combinations and
these really the relationship you see on
the script a I saw that it was going to
be the real one that they would have you
know so between them the relationship
was very similar to the one I had
written so there was a lot of work that
was already done you know because they
could just play these themes being so
similar to the characters and also
having a very similar relationship to
the one escape so that's that's why I
think that sometimes it was easier to
kind of create these looks you know
because
was for real somehow